in the past hundred years so much has
changed but not enough has remained the
same
I don't want to use the TAM
environmental friendly because friendly
people just mind and wave I want to use
the TAM environmental conscious
take a you participate your hands on you
part of the movement
60% of Kylie Jenner pigeons are running
out of food on a regular basis
what people do not realize is the fact
that the soul that they working on so
preach it can produce much crops that
today can save this community I realized
it
my name is Luther phenomena also known
as the spinach King
that looked around in the community in a
soul that there was a dying need for a
change and the change relied on me
at that particular time hence I started
the business called spinnaker
innovations why incorporates Finnish in
daily consume products to save my
community
for me what is important is the local
economy that's why I'm working with the
micro farmers in my community just so I
could give back to them and make sure
that also they have something to put on
the table let's create the world that
wanna live in together
spinach is rich in phytochemicals
syringe Eric acids to prevent you from
cardiovascular illnesses and chronic
diseases so it is in fact the medicine
spinach is the change spinach is the
solution
every day when I wake up you know I
think about my son I think about my
family you know my beautiful wife and
that's what keeps me called every day
and I'm happy I'm healthy I'm content
I believe the philosophy of slow food
not fast food food that comes from the
earth food that takes time to go why are
we rushing whatever chasing we need to
slow down
we live healthy and eat healthy we need
to enjoy food from the earth eat from
the planet and embrace life as it is and
that's what I'm doing my aim is to stay
what's left of my community and the
environment and I'll be changing
Khayelitsha
one lot of spinach bread at a time